Chúng ta sẽ đưa chào các bạn ảnh hình thường.
Hình thường này ngày 17 năm 2021, công an thành phố Hàn Nội cho biết
Lên quan đến vụ bệ cai bốn tuổi bị từ vong tại ngõ bà mi mốt với khả trả.
Fương phu dễn, Hàn Nội có quan kể rất đưa chào công an thành phố Hàn Nội đã ra quyết định hợi tụ hủ an,
hợi tụ một bí cân về tội, giữ người.
Thật đưa chào, mến nguyên nghiệp, xin năm 2020, từ chú tại sá thình lâm, tình ninh bình và bàn tị tâm,
xin năm 2020, tự chú tại sá thác hoàn, tình tinh quan, xin xong với nhau nhiều bự trồng và thuy trọt tại ngõ bà mi mốt với khả trả từ thân bà năm 2020,
ở cùng có trò hát xin năm 2020, là có xin của tâm và anh chai của hiệu cùng bị yêu.
Chúng ngày 18 năm 2020, hẹp và tâm đi trời về thi thế trò hát trên bị lấy bánh, kéo dân.
Châu dành cho ăn cụ nguyên tâm đã lấy dế bệnh đến tiếp nhiều lần vào cùng đầu và mặt trấu.
Đánh xong, tâm bắt trò hát đứng góc nhà thi thế trấu đi vệ xin đi tâm dùng tây đánh vào mặt xui vào trấu vào thăm.
Hí thế trò hát đăng nghị trong nhà về xin, kịp trử dụi tiếp tục có hình vì bỏ hành với trong hát tâm thế vệ như không ngờ gì và đi dàng hoàn.
Một lúc sau thế trong không gạo không sẽ dụng lưỡi thế thì đi dàng hoàn, sau đó trong hát được lưu đi cấp cứu ở bệnh vệ ai và tử bòng.
Qua xin đấu trang, kìa và tâm còn khai dịch tự xin bảo hành, đánh đập trong hát thậm xí bỏ đó nhiều ngày.
Cân thử vào tệ lựu trang, có quan tình rất đều trang con hành phố đã giá quy định hợi tổ hủ án, hợi tổ bị cân đường với nguyễn nghiệp về tổ giết hợi, đông thử cùng của hổ sơ sử lý bản thịt thăm thậm quy định.